you guys were a crucial part of that
announcement what do you see in terms of
functionality and to watch that you
don't already have on the desktop and
beyond mobile well I think the big
difference is productivity and speed of
access right so it's not about more
functionality it's about how quickly you
can focus in on very specific
functionality that's available on apps
that on your watch
so for example if I'm a sales manager
it's the end of the quarter I don't have
to keep pulling out my phone to keep
approving deals I want to just be able
to glance down tap it and say yeah
that's a good discount approved so
that's the key difference it's that
you've actually doing that stuff at the
end of the quarter they're checking that
frequently and that crazy they need a
glance to do so sure the we've done some
research says about the average sales
person's pulling their phone or their
pocket average person's pulling out
about a hundred 150 times a day so it's
actually a fair bit of time that adds up
is especially when you know that most
people look at their phone not for the
one thing they're looking for they start
getting distracted they find their phone
their email and so what a watch does is
keep you really focused it's a glance
it's a quick movement and that's a
really big productivity improvement for
sales people for service people for
anyone on the Chris thing Craig I
thought that the the demo of your device
of your service on the watch really
wonderfully explain what invoice to go
is the notion that that a contractor
hits the button on his wrist when he
starts working as an electrician in your
house and the second laser house stops
it's an intriguing location device why
is it so much better on a watch well I
think it the watch allows us to take it
to the next level which is currently on
the phone you have to remember to start
it and stop it
and for our small businesses cash flow
is why they're using invoice to go but
if you don't remember to start the clock
you're not going to get paid so this
allows us to geofence the location and
as soon as you start on the job site you
start billing and that makes our
customers more money because they get
the invoices out fully billing for all
the time that they spent on site do you
imagine that for the the contractors and
the like that are doing the work using
invoice to go for the width of watch
that that lets them go to a customer a
homeowner or whatever say I've hired an
electrician and they want to know if
they're on the job at the plumber was on
the job it lets me know for a fact that
they were they're working and gives that
that plumber if you will
advantage I think it absolutely does
because it's for the end customer that
receives the bill we all know the more
detail you can get the more confidence
you have that work was actually provided
and and and do you expect therefore the
watch is a business device to be a kind
of a marketing tool for the service
provider I don't know if it will be as
much of a marketing tool as it will
allow them to access more jobs because
they're gonna know that they can build
that job professionally and that's
something that we see in the small
business segment people want to be able
to act as professional as a very big
business and by able to have by being
able to have really good invoicing
really clear estimates all these things
are enabled through smart phones
development talking about that process
with the first time out with a brand new
OS what did you guys have to put against
it well we've been working on wearables
for over a year I've been on the show a
couple times talking about Salesforce
where today or yesterday we launched
Salesforce for Apple watch so we have
three parts to that we have built an
application which is our cloud analytics
app the analytics cloud that people can
now personally glance at data and drill
into it in a very simple almost gamified
way we also built a developer kit so
Salesforce where allows people to take
that Apple watch framework and then use
the Salesforce cloud platform to build
amazing absent without having to
actually go into the app OS or the
they're still gonna use the Apple tools
as well but what you get with the
Salesforce one cloud is the biggest
cloud app in the world they get security
identity work flow all the things you'd
need to build a business application
really really fast that people are using
on our Salesforce one mobile app and now
they can extend it to a watch really
quickly it was it was great for us I
mean one of the things that's really
interesting is less the technical
challenge although you know managing
security is important for building
business apps but it's also learning how
to rebuild apps for the watch it's not
the same as taking your iPhone and just
shrinking it down it's rethinking how
are people gonna use this in a very
quick glanceable way to become more
productive Greg oh I was surprised that
you guys put your reviewer
his limited resources a surprise your
company put took your limited resources
as a focus development on this watch
it's surely good for marketing purposes
we put you on Bloomberg West but but is
it you know why did you make that choice
you know and not choose to develop for
other platforms that are more widely
news because we always believe in the
small business person wanting to make
themselves more efficient with
technology if there's something that
invoice to go has proven it's that small
business people absolutely want to adopt
these new platforms but you have to do
it in a way that's extremely practical
and in our case helps people to make
more money and so it was a no-brainer
for us to use the watchkit